OK, good morning all.
So before we begin,
I just thought I'd show you a
little news item that I happened
to read that was very relevant
to what we covered recently in
So you recall when we did the
digital section a few days ago
last Thursday,
we talked about a switch.
We talked about the MOSFET
switch, which when turned on and
off, by input signals could help
build gates which would then be
combined in tens of millions of
quantities and go into chips
like the Pentium 4 and AMD
Athlon 64, and so on it so
forth.
So I just saw this news item
that I came across,
and this says they are
rethinking the basic
construction of the products.
It talks about the
semiconductor manufacturers like
AMD, Intel, and others that
build digital chips.
They are rethinking the basic
construction of the products
down to the architecture of the
transistor.
That's a MOS transistor,
and the on/off switch inside
the chip.
OK, now this might imply that
there is a single switch inside
the chip, but no,
there's tens of millions of
transistors, or tens of millions
of switches inside a chip.
And pretty much any advancement
that can be made to the basic
transistor can have a 10 million
to 20 million times effect
because there are that many of
them on a single chip.
So I thought that was very
appropriate.
OK.
Let's dive into a quick review.
So this week,
we had begun nonlinear
analysis, and I just thought I'd
blast through a few animations
that I've created,
trying to give you more insight
into the behavior of some of the
things that we have done.
Now first of all,
as I did the last time,
let me try to put it in
perspective most of what you've
learned thus far,
and what we will be learning
today.
So the past week,
we have been focusing on
nonlinear analysis.
And as I pointed out,
here is how this fits into the
big picture.
So, we had our 6.002 world,
at what we said is that we are
engineers.
We are going to devise our own
playground in which to play with
our own rules.
And that's our playground.
That's what we're going to
learn about in 002,
and for that matter,
the rest of EECS at MIT.
It's all within this playground
here.
And this is the playground with
lumped circuit abstraction,
and good old KVL,
KCl, node method,
your basic composition rules
apply within this playground
that directly come from
Maxwell's equations because you
have made the lumped matter
discipline assumptions.
OK, so then we said a large
part of the playground is
linear, and some other much more
intuitive techniques apply
within the linear portion of
that playground,
techniques like the
superposition,
Thevenin and Norton.
In most exercises,
and quizzes,
and experiments,
and so on that you do in real
life, you can pretty much apply
these simple techniques.
Very rarely do you have to go
into the node method for
circuits that are more
complicated than single source
and a couple of elements.
And then, there's the nonlinear
part.
Remember, the reason I showed
this is that this is the same
playground.
OK, linear and nonlinear are
part of the same playground.
OK, even nonlinear elements are
lumped circuit elements,
and they follow KVL,
KCl, the node equation,
and so on.
And then, last week we spent
some time talking about the
digital abstraction.
So we focused on a smaller
region of the playground.
And the assumptions we made in
there were even tighter.
We said that it is part of the
playground we shall only deal
with binary values.
We'll digitize or lump values
into highs and lows,
and that's where our circuits
are going to be.
And these circuits,
when looked at as a whole,
were nonlinear.
So, this is a simple NAND gate
circuit.
And this is the input/output
characteristic.
So, for example,
if I hold B at zero,
and I apply a zero to one
transition at A,
then this is the output that I
will see at C.
So notice, this is decidedly
nonlinear.
Then I said that,
look, suppose we had to fix the
input values at a given set.
OK, so let's say,
for example,
I fix A at one,
and B at one.
OK, and then look at the
circuit in this situation.
What do I find?
What I find is that the entire
digital set of circuits that we
were looking at move over into
the linear space for a given set
of switch settings,
OK?
So, when I set A 1 and B 1,
A equal to one and B equal to
one, my NAND gate becomes like
this.
OK, it's a simple resistive
network with a voltage source,
VS.
So, for a fixed set of inputs,
for a given set of inputs,
if I don't change my inputs,
then my circuit looks like a
linear circuit,
and my good old linear analysis
techniques apply.
So that was last week.
And this week,
we are looking at the nonlinear
space.
And we looked at a couple of
techniques in the nonlinear
space, analytical techniques and
graphical techniques.
And then, I showed you an
example.
OK, I showed you an example
circuit that was something that
I would like to build involving
the light emitting expo dweeb,
my little garage door opener
thingamajig, and I wanted to
transmit music over that light
beam.
I also showed you that it was
highly distorted because it was
in the nonlinear space.
So, today what I'm going to do
is introduce a new part of the
playground.
There's a new part of the
playground, and I'll show you a
technique whereby by focusing on
this part of the playground and
disciplining ourselves in the
kind of inputs we apply to
circuits, I'm going to show you
that certain kinds of nonlinear
circuits also move over,
when used in a particular way,
also move into the linear
analysis domain.
OK, so let me leave that for
now and go back into quickly
reviewing the motivating example
of music that I had taken last
time.
OK, so here was a little
example.
So I have a music source,
VI, and I apply that.
This device that I call the,
lightheartedly,
the Light Emitting Expo Dweeb
has a current,
VD, across it,
or a voltage,
and a current ID through it.
And the light intensity,
I said, was proportional to the
current.
And because of that,
I was able to get the light to
impinge on a receiving device,
which produced a current that
was proportional to the
intensity of light falling on
it.
And that signal would then be
amplified somehow.
We haven't talked about all of
this stuff yet.
This will happen next week.
But let's say we somehow
amplify the signal and then
played out through a set of
speakers.
All right, so if I had some
sort of a music signal here,
then I could then transmit the
music signal over to the side on
top of this light beam.
But the problem,
as I said the last time,
was that our device,
the Light Emitting Expo Dweeb
had an exponential
characteristic,
so that I had some trouble in
getting undistorted music.
So, the characteristic of the
VI characteristics of my device
looked like so.
The ID versus VD curve looked
as follows.
OK, it was decidedly nonlinear.
And because of that,
I was getting a lot of
distortions in my signal,
and I showed you a little trick
to plot, given an input waveform
at a transfer function such as
here to plot the output
function.
OK, let me show you another
little animation that I have
created here for you that should
give you even more intuition in
terms of how it happens.
So, this is a characteristic I
showed you up here.
It's on both sides,
but I guess it points to only
one unless I shuttle back and
forth really fast.
So on average,
I'll be in both places.
But anyway, so here's my ID
versus VD characteristic.
And as I said,
there's an exponential ID
versus VD curve.
And I want to see what the
output looks like,
for example,
a sinusoidal input.
So I said, let's place the
input along a little graph,
rotate it so,
and take a sinusoid,
and apply a sinusoid to the
input, VI, which would also
appear across the Light Emitting
Expo Dweeb.
And then, what I wanted to see
was how the output looked.
OK, so let me tell you that the
output is going to look like
this.
OK, the output is going to look
like so.
And, a little artifice to
discover curves like this is to
think about a point here
corresponding to the point on
the transfer curve here,
because this is VD,
looking at the Y intercept.
That's a value of ID,
and that's a value of ID here.
And, time moves along here,
and time moves along here.
So, I did this little
animation.
You'd better be impressed.
It took me six hours to do it.
So, here it goes.
So, let's say I start by
focusing on this little point
that corresponds to this point
on the transfer function,
which then, in turn,
points to a time,
zero, this point on my ID
curve.
OK, I hope this works.
So, as my point moves down
[LAUGHTER], this was fun to do,
I promise you.
So notice that as this point
has the following excursion,
this had the following
excursions here.
OK, all right.
So let me pause that little
animation there.
At the end of the lecture,
I'll put that up again if you
like, and you all can come and
play with it.
So, you can actually do this in
PowerPoint.
It took me quite a bit of time
to figure out how to do it,
though, but it's fun.
OK, so let me show you a little
demo, and show you a sinusoid,
and show you what the output
looks like if I apply a sinusoid
for VI.
So, I'll show you ID as a
function of VI when VI is a
sinusoid.
There you go.
So, I applied my sinusoid VI,
and this is the current that I
get.
And notice, this is the
transfer function that I talked
about, the ID versus VD curve of
my Light Emitting Expo Dweeb.
And I get this highly nonlinear
transformation of the input as I
get to the output.
OK, so that is a problem.
And then, I also played some
music for you.
Let's do that,
too.
I played some music for you.
I applied the music as an input
to the circuit,
and that's the output.
OK, that's the output that I'm
observing at the amplifier.
It's highly distorted.
OK, we can stop that.
There you go.
OK, so that was my problem.
OK, so we had covered,
we had gone this far last
Tuesday.
I set the problem up for you,
motivated what we had to do,
and showed you that I was able
to transmit music over my garage
door opener, but I did not think
I could listen to that music for
very long.
So, I challenged all of us to
think about how a trick that I
could use to be able to transmit
music and have a linear
response.
So, did you people get time to
think about it?
So how many people here think
they know the answer?
It's OK, don't be modest.
Go ahead.
Could you speak louder?
Yeah, you find another
something, kind of element,
that's got the opposite graph
so that when you add them
together.
Oh, this guy wants to cheat.
No.
He wants a new element.
So, no, no new elements.
Pardon?
Build an MP3 encoder.
Ah-ha, so that will happen much
later.
Yes?
Digitize the signal before you
send it to the LED?
send it to the LED.
But in some sense,
each of these solutions is a
huge sledgehammer approach to
look at solving it.
There's a much simpler
technique I can apply here.
Yeah?
Add a voltage offset.
Ah, ah-ha, that might work.
What else?
So let's say,
here's my signal,
right?
If I add a voltage offset,
that will just bump the signal
up here.
Then the curve is still
nonlinear.
But you're getting there.
Well, I'll tell you what.
Let's pause here.
Let me quit while I'm ahead.
OK, so the answer here,
folks, is Zen.
OK, what I want you to do is,
so, in Zen, what you have to do
is you have to sit down in a
courtyard, and look at a rock,
like a small rock on the
ground.
And you got a focus on it till
the rest of Earth kind of
vanishes.
Just focus on the rock.
OK, now make like you're in a
courtyard, and you're looking at
this little area here.
Just look at this.
OK, and I'll give you ten
seconds.
Sit down quietly,
and no sounds.
Just stare at the spot here.
OK, make believe this is your
little rock, and just stand
there and think about it.
OK, I'll give you five seconds
to do that.
Just stare at it.
And very soon,
the answer should pop into your
heads.
OK, what do you see?
This guy, if I focus on this
really small region of the
graph, this small little piece
looks more or less linear.
OK, hmm, so that should give me
some insight.
This whole thing,
the macrograph is nonlinear.
But I focus on a little rinky
dinky piece of that graph like
so, that appears more or less
linear.
If it's small enough,
that appears linear.
So, I'm staring at this,
and that appears linear.
The question is,
how do I exploit this little
small, little,
linear region to get a linear
response from my device.
OK, so here's the trick that
I'm going to use.
The little trick that I'm going
to use is the following.
Notice that,
let me call this voltage at the
center of this region capital
VD.
What I can do,
if I take my input signal,
and I just pointed out earlier,
I bump it up.
I boost it.
OK, so I apply a DC offset to
my input signal,
like so.
So I apply some input signal,
VI, which is also equal to the
VD if I look at a variable
across the nonlinear element.
If I apply a DC offset,
VI, and I superimpose the music
on top of that,
let me call my music,
just to distinguish between the
two, capital VI,
and the small vi.
OK, that's my music.
So here's my capital VD,
my DC offset.
And I want to superimpose my
music on top of that.
OK, so I've gotten halfway
there.
By superimposing my music here
instead of having excursions out
here, I now have excursions out
here.
OK, and so I'm using some
portion of the graph here.
But that's still way beyond the
small little element there.
So a second think that I do in
addition to boosting up the
signal is shrink it.
Think of boost and shrink,
BS.
So what I want to do is boost
up the signal using a DC offset,
and shrink the sucker.
OK, so I'm going to go with a
small signal and bump it up.
OK, so now what happens is that
small signal in its excursions,
only uses that little portion
of the graph.
OK, again, remember:
bump and shrink,
two things, boost and shrink.
So what do you think of that
trick?
So, by doing that,
what happens is that signal
that has excursions here will
produce a corresponding response
in this region,
OK?
And I argue that since this is
more or less like a straight
line, I invoke Zen here,
and argue that this little
signal now gets transformed,
and I get a linear response.
OK: boost and shrink.
So in terms of my circuit,
let me draw it out for you.
My Light Emitting Expo Dweeb,
and this whole signal was what
I used to call V capital I,
and that's made up of two
components now,
a bump offset,
and a shrunk voltage VI.
It shrunk, so therefore I've
used the small v and small i,
like, really,
really small.
In the same manner,
I get a VD ID across the LED,
and the corresponding values
here will also have a DC offset
and a small response.
Let me call that ID plus I
small d.
I'll do all this mathematically
in a second as well,
but first let me do it
completely intuitively so you
get some insight into what's
going on.
And, VD is simply capital VD
plus small vd.
OK, and this is the same as VI,
I, and VI.
OK, so what have I done?
I've done two things.
I have said,
as an engineer,
OK, I care about getting music
across my garage door opener.
And I'll do what it takes to do
that.
OK, so as an engineer,
I'll do two things.
I'm going to bump my signal up
and shrink it.
And the bumping and shrinking,
and I do it like this.
I shrink my signal,
the music signal here,
and add a DC offset.
OK, and I claim that the music
I listened on the other side
now, provided I have enough
amplification there,
is going to be undistorted.
OK, so far I've showing this to
you completely intuitively using
little sketches,
no math.
I promise you,
I'll give you a bunch of math
in a few seconds,
but just get the basic idea,
and get the intuition behind
it.
So let's go back to our demo
and take a look.
So remember,
BS, right, bump and shrink.
So what I'm going to do is
first of all,
let me bump up the signal.
So, what I'll do is I want to
add an offset to my input,
and let me bump it up.
Let me shrink it first.
It'll make the point a little
clearer.
So, the big input,
green, is a big input.
Let me shrink it.
OK, so I've made my input
small, and in the middle of that
picture out there,
you see the region of the
transfer curve that's being
articulated.
OK, this region of the curve is
being articulated by the small
signal.
It's a much smaller signal.
And the output is still
distorted because I have to do
two things: bump and shrink.
I've only shrunk.
OK, let me bump it up now.
What's the yellow curve?
It's going to get linear.
It's going to get proportional
to the input.
Then I'm bumping it up now.
I can make it smaller,
make it even smaller,
there you go.
Isn't that fantastic?
So, I'm making nature do my
bidding here,
OK?
So, this is one of those,
when I learned electronics and
so on many, many years ago,
this was one of those really
big ah-ha moments for me,
saying, wow,
that stuff is cool.
It's something that I couldn't
think about myself,
and it's not obvious,
and by being disciplined and
creative in how I use circuits,
I can do really,
really cool things.
OK, remember this as a big
ah-ha moment for you.
So, here's my little signal
that I've shrunk and bumped up,
and my output is a sinusoid,
and not this funny,
distorted waveform.
And notice that this is the
region of the curve that is
being articulated.
So, I can make the signal even
smaller if I like.
OK, and what I'd like to do
next is play music for you,
and if you don't believe your
eyes, you can at least believe
your ears.
Let me go to the distorted
signal again,
switch to music,
and raise it up.
OK, now what we'll do is shrink
the music signal and then bump
it up.
Can I turn the volume down a
little bit?
That's good.
OK, so if I shrunk the volume a
little bit, and let me bump it
up, now.
[MUSIC PLAYS] Just remember
this as a big ah-ha moment.
OK, the signal is really,
really small.
I like that.
I like the enthusiasm.
OK, so the signal's very small,
and I get a more or less linear
response.
OK.
All right, so that's intuition,
and the approach that I've
taken is called,
it's variously called small
signal analysis,
incremental analysis,
small signal method,
small signal discipline,
whatever you want.
OK, this simply says that by
boosting and shrinking my
signal, I get a response that's
more or less linear even when I
have a nonlinear device.
And this technique is called
the small signal approach.
So, just to focus on that a
little bit longer,
switch to page five of your
notes and let me draw something
out for you.
OK, so what I have here,
this is my offset VD,
and from the VD offset I have
my little signal V small d,
and the total signal is called
V capital D.
Offset, small signal,
and that's my total signal.
OK, notice the offset is all
capital.
The total signal is small v
capital D, and the music or the
small signal is small v small d.
Similarly, the output is going
to look like this,
and here I get an offset in the
output ID.
I get a corresponding signal,
I small d, and I get a total
signal, I capital D,
OK?
The cool thing to notice is
that the signal here,
the output signal here
corresponding to the input
signal, the music signal,
VD, is small I small D,
and that is more or less
linear.
OK, and I can even plot the
signal like so.
This is my input,
v capital D.
That's T.
This is VD, V small d.
That is my total input.
And similarly,
I have an output.
And this is my output ID.
And, that looks like this,
I capital D,
small i small d,
total signal I capital D.
OK, so that's the small signal
method.
So, let me summarize that for
you.
There are three steps to the
method.
So, first of all,
operate at some DC offset.
This is also called DC bias,
and in that example it's VDID.
OK, so I choose an operating
point that bumps up the
operation in some region of
interest.
The second step is to
superimpose small signal on top
of VD, capital V capital D,
to superimpose a small signal,
and the third step is observe
the response --
-- and the response,
small i small d,
that's the music part of the
response, ID,
is approximately linear.
OK, three steps to the method
here, and just remember this
notation.
And, my notation in the small
signal model is as follows.
My total signal ID is the sum
of two signals,
I capital D plus small i small
d.
This is called the total
signal.
That's called the DC offset.
And this is the superimposed
small signal.
OK, total signal,
DC offset, plus the small
signal.
And sometimes,
especially when doing math,
and so on, we may oftentimes
represent ID as a delta,
I capital D,
OK, to show that ID is
incremental change in the value
of I capital D.
And because of that,
this method is also often
called the incremental method,
incremental analysis.
OK, so far what I've done is
given you some intuition.
I've developed a small,
simple method,
given you some insight into why
we use this method,
and also shown you some
demonstrations that show that
when I bump and shrink,
and observe the response,
I do get a more or less linear
response.
So let me now do this
mathematically and show you that
mathematically,
you can also derive your
response to be a linear
response.
This is page seven.
So, I know that ID is some
function of the diode voltage.
F was my nonlinear function.
OK, so my function F was a
nonlinear function.
So therefore,
ID was nonlinearly related to
VD.
So, let's do the math.
So as a first step,
what we did was replace VD by a
DC offset, the small signal
method, a DC offset,
plus a small incremental
change.
OK, by doing the math,
let me simply use the delta VD
notation to show you that I'm
dealing with small increments,
and also because in the
mathematics community,
when you learn about some of
these techniques,
they will use the incremental
change notation,
which is the delta VD notation.
In electrical engineering,
we use a small v,
small d notation.
So, this is a large DC offset,
and this is a small change
about that offset.
So, you folks have taken math
courses before,
and been looking at finding out
the value of a function,
which is a small change for an
input value, which is a small
change about a big input value
or a big DC point is Taylor's
expansion.
OK, so let's use Taylor's
series expansion,
OK, and substitute VD plus
delta VD into this,
and see what ID looks like.
Again, let me tell you where
I'm going with this.
ID equals F of VD.
This is a nonlinear function,
OK?
I claim that by replacing VD,
the input, with the DC offset
plus a small value,
the resulting response to the
small value will be linear,
OK?
So what I'm going to do next is
replace VD with this sum here,
and then do the math,
and show you that the response
corresponding,
or the change in ID
corresponding to the change in
VD is going to be linear.
All right, so let's expand this
function using Taylor's series
near the DC offset point,
capital V capital D.
OK, so ID is simply,
by Taylor's series,
I want to find out a value of
the function close to V capital
D.
OK, so I take the value of the
function at that point,
and then I add a few terms in
my Taylor's series expansion.
The first term is simply the
good old Taylor's series stuff.
OK, the first term is the first
derivative of the function times
the change.
And then, the second one is
second derivative.
OK, and then I get higher order
terms.
So this is nothing new here.
This is good old Taylor series
expansion, and again,
let me tell you where I'm
going.
I want to look at the response
for an input that looks like
this, and I want to show you at
the end of the day that the
response in ID,
the effect on ID of using an
input like this is as if that
effect, the incremental change
is linearly related to the small
input, delta VD.
So here's my Taylor's series
expansion for delta V.
Now remember,
I told you that delta VD is
much, much smaller than V
capital D.
OK, it's a very,
very small quantity.
But that quantity is really
very small.
Then what I'm going to get is
that my output is,
I can begin to ignore my second
order terms.
OK, delta VD is very,
very, very small.
Then, what I'm going to do is
that ignore higher order terms.
So I'll go and ignore higher
order terms.
They'll all go to zero.
Remember, I can do this because
by design I've chosen delta VD
to be very, very,
very small.
OK, remember,
we are engineers.
I've chosen it in a way that
this is very small.
OK, so I'm telling you that's
the case, and under those
conditions, I can ignore second
higher order terms,
in which case I am left with
this expression here.
So let me rewrite this.
Let me rewrite this down here.
OK, I've just copied this
turnout, I've ignored all these
terms here, and so I have a more
or less equal to sign that
remains.
So what I'm going to do is when
I apply a small input of this
form to a large DC offset,
my output is also going to look
like some output offset with a
change in the output offset.
And let me call the output
offset I capital D,
and some small change in the
output delta ID.
OK, we'll make sure we can
convince ourselves that this is
indeed the case.
Notice that this guy here,
F of capital V capital D is a
constant.
That's a constant with respect
to the incremental change,
delta VD.
Similarly, this part here is a
constant.
Notice that this term here is
the first derivative of the
function evaluated at the DC
bias point, capital V capital D.
OK, so this term is also a
constant with respect to delta
VD.
So notice, then,
I have a constant term plus a
constant term multiplying a
small change,
delta VD.
So what I can do next is,
in this case,
given that I have a constant
term on both sides,
and on this side it's a time
varying term,
what I can do is equate the two
constant terms.
I can go ahead and equate these
two terms.
Remember, I have a constant
plus a time varying term,
OK, if I'm assuming here that
delta VD, my little music signal
is a time varying term.
So, this constant will equal
this, so ID must equal F of VD.
And I know that's the case
because the function evaluated
at the DC offset gives me the DC
current ID.
And similarly,
ID is equal to that component.
Delta ID is equal to D,
F of --
OK, so my incremental change in
the output is the first
derivative multiplied by the
small change in the current.
OK, so I'm pretty much done.
So, therefore,
notice that delta ID is
proportional to delta VD.
OK, and that's what I had set
out to show.
Remember, I had set out to show
that provided my input is a
small excursion around a large
DC offset,
then my output could also be a
large DC offset with a small
excursion on top of it where the
two excursions,
the input excursion and the
output excursion would be
linearly related like so.
OK, and the method is very
simple.
I simply expanded the function
about that point,
that DC point,
neglected higher order terms,
and notice that my incremental
term was simply the derivative
plus the incremental change,
a derivative times the
incremental change in the input.
Move onto page nine,
and I'd like to give you a
quick graphical interpretation
of this.
So I gave an intuitive
explanation earlier.
This is a mathematical
explanation that shows you that
the input could be linearly
related to the output,
provided, the outputs would be
linearly related to the input,
provided the input has a DC
offset, and small excursions
about that DC offset.
So, let me give you some
intuition in what you've really
done here, using a little graph
here.
So, I'm going to plot ID versus
VD, and notice that I have some
point here, V capital D,
I capital D.
That's my DC bias.
So, I have some DC bias point
here.
OK, what is this?
That is simply the slope of the
curve at that point.
OK, it's the slope of this
curve evaluated at this point.
So this guy here is simply the
slope of this curve evaluated at
ID VD.
OK, now, what I care about is
this point here,
and this point here.
So let's say that this is delta
VD, all right,
and that corresponds to this
point here.
So what I've done is taken the
slope and multiplied that by
delta VD.
So I've taken the slope,
and multiplied it by delta VD,
OK, and that gives me this
component here.
OK, and so, this is the point
that I'm going to get.
So in other words,
what I've done is approximated
point A using the Taylor trick
by the point B.
OK, so this is a point,
A, which is what I really want,
and I've approximated that by
taking the slope of the function
at V capital D,
and multiplying that by the
change in the input to get the
corresponding Y offset,
and that's the point that I
get.
And notice that if I make this
delta VD small enough,
then the error between these
two points becomes smaller and
smaller.
So back to our example,
so ID was a e to the BVD.
This was the relation for our
Expo Dweeb, and let me just plug
in the values.
So, ID plus small id.
Notice, I'm just shuttling back
and forth between the notation
delta VD, and small v small d.
OK, and so that is given by a e
to the BVD, oops,
plus, I'm just writing that
equation up there.
Let me call this equation X.
And so, I get the second term
is the derivative,
ab times e to the BVD times
delta VD, small VD,
and equating this term that the
DC offset.
Notice that this is the DC
offset in the output,
and the small signal,
ID is, further notice that in
this particular example,
what's that?
a e to the BVD.
That's simply ID again.
It just happens to be that way
in this example.
So, I get ID times BVD.
So, for my input,
small id, my incremental change
in the output is some ID times B
times VD.
And notice that this is a
constant.
And because that is a constant,
my small signal behavior ID is
going to be linearly related to
the signal, VD,
the input signal VD.
OK, in the last three minutes,
I'd like to give you one
additional insight.
So what we've shown so far is
if I have an offset and a small
change above it,
then my output ID will be
linearly related to my input.
Now let's stare at this thing
again.
Let me rewrite it.
It's some constant IDB times
VD.
So, where have we seen such an
expression before?
OK, where ID was some constant
times VD.
OK, remember,
I equals V divided by R:
Ohm's law.
What I want to show you now is
how we constantly keep
simplifying our lives.
The moment we hit some
complication and things get too
painful to analyze,
as engineers,
we come up with some clever
tricks to make an analysis and
use of circuits simple again.
And so, notice that this is
similar to some,
one by RD VD,
where RD is simply one over
IDB.
I'm just defining this to be
RD.
And what that means is that I
can take a nonlinear circuit
that looks like this.
OK, and what I can do is
replace this by its incremental
equivalent, and build what is
called a small signal circuit.
And I'll just introduce it
here.
And we will revisit the circuit
in much more gory detail a
couple of weeks from now.
So, what I can do is build a
small signal circuit where I
have all the small signal
variables, and replace a
nonlinear device by a simple
little resistor whose value is
given by IDB.
OK, so therefore,
what I can do is take my
nonlinear circuit,
and for small,
incremental changes,
replace that circuit with this
equivalent small signal circuit,
and go back to doing simple
stuff again.
Thank you.